Donald Trump over the weekend has done
something that was inconceivable for a
president to do before Donald Trump but
now that every day is a scandal it
doesn't even get the attention that it
deserves everything has changed and in a
completely incoherent way that only
Donald Trump can do things Donald Trump
started to foment rebellion on Twitter
and at his press briefings against the
public health measures to slow the
spread of coronavirus supporting the
completely dangerous and ignorant
protests of the Infowars types of the
don't tread on me types of the magg
people who are mass gathering without
masks without social distancing to
demand that their states reopen in the
midst of the current coronavirus
pandemic as many of these states are
seeing rapidly on a percentage basis
rapidly increasing cases Donald Trump
tweeting over the weekend as the protest
mount quote liberate Minnesota liberate
Michigan liberate Virginia and save your
great Second Amendment it is under siege
few things can make people turn to
violence like a Republican president
telling his followers that their gun
rights are under siege then Trump
defending the protesters during his
press briefings despite their completely
irresponsible lack of social distancing
and masks Trump defending them saying
hey listen some of these restrictions
are too tough well I think we do have a
so green guidance but I think some
things are too tough and if you look at
some of the states you just mentioned it
it's too tough not only relative to this
but what they've done in Virginia with
respect to the Second Amendment is just
a horrible thing they did a horrible
thing the governor and he's the governor
under a cloud to start off with so when
you see what he said about the Second
Amendment when you see what other states
have done no I think I feel very
comfortable go ahead
just to be clear when you talk about
these states Michigan Minnesota Virginia
do you think that they should lift their
stay at home orders or can you talk to
Knoblauch I think elements of what
they've done is too much it's just too
much you know the elements because I've
already said sir are you concerned
though that people coming out in
protests are going to spread coded to
other people they're congregating in
ways that health experts have said they
should not know these are people
expressing their views I see where they
are I see the way they're working they
seem to be very responsible people to me
but it's you know they've been treated a
little bit rough there it is the
protesters are being treated roughly the
people in states are being treated
roughly but the behavior of the
protesters at mass rallies when there
are distancing guidelines from the
federal government that's all fine
apparently now understand how
incomprehensible this is first Trump
claimed to have absolute authority over
the states which he doesn't have
eventually somebody clearly got to trump
and said listen you don't have the
authority
so Trump did a 180 and in his plan to
reopen he said this is all totally up to
the governors which is true it is but
now Trump is supporting rebellion
against the governor's who Trump said he
is confident in to do the right thing
this is much worse than merely egging on
protesters in a vacuum which is bad
enough Trump is actually encouraging
people to violate the guidelines which
he set at the federal level and has a
states to follow he's encouraging risky
behavior from a public health
perspective it's going to lead to more
infections and deaths it's just a matter
of math this language of liberating
states he's using language which can
only serve to encourage horrible
behavior and then Trump's tweets equally
erratic throughout the weekend including
a bunch of tweets going after states
about them having to do more more
testing which is hilarious because all
along Trump's argument has been testing
is perfect and it's because of him now
when it becomes undeniable that we
simply don't have enough testing to
reopen and we'll talk about that more
tomorrow
Trump starts sending tweets out about
how listen these state governors really
have to get testing figured out and then
around the same time as he sent those
liberation tweets he included a tax on
the World Health Organization another
scapegoat now for his terrible
leadership as well as going after
Democrats like Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer claiming they're on vacation
when of course they're no more on
vacation than you know congressman Dan
Crenshaw and every Republican and
Democrat in the House and Senate all of
whom are simply in their districts right
now during the quarantine rather than in
Washington DC so this was never funny it
was it was always horrifying but now
it's extra not funny as it becomes more
and more dangerous and there will be
more death as a result of this and
unfortunately it's increasingly looking
like there will be violence as a result
of this at some point as well if it
hasn't started already
and we will soon hear about it follow us
on Instagram for continued coverage of
all of these whacked-out protests we are
at david pakman show on instagram
today's program is sponsored in part by
the galaxies series which is a series of
three books written by a really great
author I thought and I would call the
genre sort of political science fiction
I've really enjoyed the books it looks
at the future it explores what could
happen to Planet Earth if we stay on our
path environmentally it deals with space
travel it takes a sort of deep dive into
political psychology and it's a really
intriguing sort of dystopian look at the
future the stories are told from a
perspective that I think people in the
audience would really appreciate and
there's a ton of really excellent
artwork also that accompanies the books
I read a lot of books in this genre and
I'll tell you these books are very
well-written the plot the characters are
compelling if you're someone who likes
politics and sci-fi you'll really like
these books again it's the galaxy series
check it out for yourself you can find
it at david pakman.com slash galaxy